Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Quando qualcuno ci chiede
quali lingue parliamo,
le risposte più comuni sono:
l'italiano, ovviamente;
l'inglese, probabilmente;
forse il francese e lo spagnolo,
che in fin dei conti
sono simili all'italiano,
o almeno così dicono.
Ma c'è una lingua che noi tutti parliamo,
senza neanche accorgercene,
ed è la lingua del tatto.
Come neuroscienziato,
mi occupo da alcuni anni
dello studio del tatto
ed in particolare della percezione
del tatto affettivo;
o, in altre parole, delle carezze
e del ruolo che questa modalità svolge
nel modo in cui percepiamo
noi stessi e gli altri.
Apprendiamo la lingua tattile,
tramite gli altri, fin dalla nascita.
Addirittura, alcuni studi mostrano come,
ancora prima di nascere,
il feto risponda con dei movimenti attivi
quando la mamma si accarezza la pancia.
Questa comunicazione tattile pre-nascita
può avere degli effetti positivi
sulla regolazione affettiva del bambino
dopo la nascita.
Siamo uno dei pochi animali
a nascere prematuro,
il che significa che abbiamo
bisogno degli altri per sopravvivere.
Non possiamo nutrirci;
non possiamo coprirci o scoprirci,
se sentiamo freddo o caldo;
non possiamo camminare,
perché il nostro sistema motorio
non è ancora pienamente sviluppato.
I nostri caregivers, quindi,
devono aiutarci a sopravvivere;
ed il modo in cui lo fanno
è sempre, e inevitabilmente,
attraverso il tatto.
La pratica dello “skin-to-skincare”,
fin dalla nascita,
ha infatti un'importanza fondamentale
nel riprodurre in qualche modo
quella sensazione di calore,
di protezione, di contenimento
che il feto provava quando era cullato
dal liquido amniotico nel grembo materno.
Il modo in cui siamo toccati
dai nostri caregivers
ha un'importanza cruciale
non solo per il nostro sviluppo
emotivo e cognitivo,
ma anche per il modo in cui usiamo
e useremo questa lingua a nostra volta,
quindi a livello sociale.
Per esempio, abbiamo dimostrato
come il modo in cui i bambini di un anno
sono toccati dalle proprie madri
durante un'attività giornaliera,
come per esempio sfogliare
un libro insieme,
ha un effetto diretto
sul modo in cui il bambino
userà questo linguaggio, a sua volta,
nei confronti della mamma,
specialmente quando si tratta
di un tatto negativo,
caratterizzato da restrizioni
e strattonamenti.
Nel corso della nostra vita
siamo, costantemente,
esposti a questa lingua;
e di conseguenza, ne diventiamo fluenti.
La utilizziamo giornalmente,
sia con le persone care
che con gli sconosciuti.
C'è una caratteristica del tatto
che ci unisce nella diversità,
che ci rende tutti uguali
nella disuguaglianza:
il tatto è mediato dalla pelle,
è il nostro organo più vasto
in termini di dimensioni e di funzioni.
Il nostro corpo è interamente
coperto di pelle,
che è ciò che ci connette
in modo diretto con il mondo esterno.
La pelle è l'unico organo
ad essere esposto in modo simmetrico
sia all'interno del nostro corpo
che all'esterno,
ed è un organo sensoriale
molto sofisticato.
Al suo interno ci sono
tantissimi recettori,
che ci aiutano a percepire il dolore,
il piacere, la temperatura, il solletico..
Ovviamente, queste sensazioni
non sono formate nella pelle,
ma essa rappresenta l'interfaccia
tramite la quale questi segnali,
per via del midollo spinale,
raggiungono le diverse parti del cervello.
Qui, poi, questi segnali
vengono interpretati
e percepiti come caldi,
freddi, dolorosi, piacevoli,
sulla base delle loro caratteristiche.
Possiamo dire che la pelle
è a tutti gli effetti un filtro.
Che da una parte funge
da scudo protettivo,
mettendoci in guardia da pericoli fisici,
come una potenziale lesione,
attraverso la percezione del dolore;
pericoli ambientali,
quindi mantenendo
la nostra termoregolazione
e facendoci, per esempio,
tremare per il freddo
o sudare per il caldo;
ma anche pericoli sociali,
attraverso quella sensazione
di non sentirci a nostro agio
quando qualcuno ci tocca
in un modo non appropriato.
Ma la pelle ci connette
anche al mondo esterno,
in maniera diretta,
aiutandoci ad esempio
a riconoscere gli oggetti
attraverso il tatto.
Tramite la pelle, siamo anche in grado
di percepire emozioni.
Vi è mai capitato di ascoltare
la vostra canzone preferita
ad un concerto,
o il racconto di un evento speciale
accaduto alla vostra migliore amica,
e di avere la pelle d'oca?
Quante volte abbiamo sentito
qualcuno dire:
"Sento tutto a pelle",
"l'ho sentito a pelle",
"Quella persona non mi
è piaciuta a pelle".
Ci sono, infatti, vari modi
attraverso i quali la pelle comunica
e ci aiuta a comunicare,
ed il tatto è forse
la modalità più eclatante.
Per esempio, quanti di voi
prestano attenzione
alla prima stretta di mano,
quando incontriamo qualcuno
per la prima volta?
Ma perché ci si stringe la mano?
È un vero e proprio biglietto da visita.
Ed è stato dimostrato
che la prima stretta di mano
conti tanto quanto il curriculum,
durante un colloquio di lavoro.
È un modo in cui colmiamo
la distanza fisica tra noi e l'altro
per la prima volta.
Ci costringe ad avvicinarci:
e si narra che fosse un modo
per assicurarsi che l'altra persona
non avesse un'arma nella propria mano.
Rimane poi come il simbolo
della firma di un contratto;
e ad oggi lo utilizziamo
come un modo per formarci
una prima impressione dell'altro,
indipendentemente dal fatto
che sia accurata o meno.
Come ogni lingua, esistono differenze
geografiche e culturali.
Da 12 anni vivo e lavoro nel Nord Europa,
nel Regno Unito prima e poi in Svezia;
e molte volte mi sono sentita in imbarazzo
in situazioni nelle quali
la distanza interpersonale
era diversa da quella a cui ero abituata.
Mi sono ovviamente dovuta adeguare:
ma ammetto di aver sentito
una vera e propria fame tattile,
in situazioni nelle quali un abbraccio,
o una pacca sulla spalla,
sarebbero stati d'aiuto.
Queste differenze geografiche e culturali
sono visibili non solo
nelle interazioni tra sconosciuti,
ma anche tra amici e congiunti.
Per esempio, alcuni studi
si sono focalizzati sulla frequenza
con cui coppie di innamorati
si toccano in luoghi pubblici,
come ad esempio un bar o un ristorante.
Uno dei primi studi
fu pubblicato negli anni '60,
e trovò delle differenze eclatanti.
A Puerto Rico, per esempio,
le coppie si toccavano una media
di 180 volte in un'ora;
a Parigi si toccavano 110 volte;
in Florida, si toccavano due volte;
e a Londra non si toccavano mai
(Risate).
Studi di questo tipo ci mostrano
che tendenzialmente nei paesi del Nord
ci si tocca molto meno
che nei paesi del Sud,
anche tra innamorati.
Ma senza dubbio, il tatto gioca un ruolo
fondamentale nella nostra vita,
dalla nascita fino alla vecchiaia,
quando solitamente ci sono
meno opportunità
per interazioni tattili e sociali.
Toccarsi, quindi, è più di una semplice
stimolazione sensoriale sulla pelle:
ha un valore comunicativo potente.
Richiede fiducia e vicinanza fisica:
richiede con-tatto.
In uno dei nostri studi abbiamo dimostrato
come le persone siano
estremamente accurate
nel leggere le intenzioni altrui,
sulla base di come le persone
usano il tatto nei loro confronti.
Abbiamo dimostrato
come un tatto lento e delicato
è più probabile che venga associato
con l'intenzione di voler comunicare
supporto e vicinanza.
Al contrario, un tatto più veloce e vivace
è più probabile che venga interpretato
come un segnale di avvertimento,
come se l'altra persona
voglia attirare la nostra attenzione.
Questi diversi tipi di tatto
attivano diversi recettori
sulla nostra pelle,
e di conseguenza attivano
diverse aree cerebrali.
Anche per questo vengono poi letti,
e interpretati, in chiave diversa.
Sicuramente, molti di voi avranno visto
questo video molto toccante
di una donna con Alzheimer,
ex prima ballerina,
che non appena riceve
una carezza sulla propria mano
riesce a ricordare
la coreografia de"Il Cigno Nero".
Questo perché il tatto
ci connette agli altri;
ed in modo forse meno intuitivo,
ci connette anche a noi stessi.
Proprio come la parola,
il tatto può rappresentare
un ponte tra passato e presente,
una finestra sui nostri ricordi
e su noi stessi.
A questo riguardo,
eravamo curiosi di capire
se questo tipo di tatto, lento e delicato,
possa giocare un ruolo importante
nel modo in cui diventiamo
consapevoli del nostro corpo,
se comparato ad un tipo
di tatto più veloce.
Abbiamo invitato i partecipanti
nel nostro laboratorio,
e li abbiamo sottoposti
alla famosa illusione della mano di gomma.
La mano del partecipante viene coperta,
e poi si pone di fronte a loro
una mano di gomma realistica.
E poi si tocca la mano del partecipante,
e la mano di gomma, in maniera analoga,
quindi allo stesso modo
e allo stesso ritmo.
Dopo meno di un minuto
di stimolazione visiva e tattile,
circa il 70-80 percento delle persone
percepisce l'illusione
che la mano di gomma diventi la loro mano.
Quindi integrano, in maniera
temporanea, la mano di gomma
nella loro rappresentazione corporea.
Quando questa illusione viene indotta
utilizzando un tocco più lento e delicato,
piuttosto che un tocco veloce,
abbiamo misurato
un aumento dell'illusione.
In altre parole,
questo tipo di tocco lento e delicato,
che ha le caratteristiche di una carezza,
sembra giocare un ruolo molto importante
nel modo in cui riconosciamo
il nostro corpo come tale.
Se ripensiamo al fatto
che fin dalla nascita
siamo costantemente abbracciati e toccati,
questo potrebbe suggerire
che è attraverso il tatto
dei nostri caregivers,
che siamo in grado di costruire
un senso di noi stessi.
Il tatto, quindi, ci aiuta a capire
dove finisce me stesso
e dove inizia l'altro.
Questi studi scientifici,
che mostrano l'importanza del tatto
per lo sviluppo umano,
possono anche fornirci uno scorcio
sulle conseguenze della mancanza di tatto
nel corso della nostra vita.
A questo riguardo, studi condotti
negli orfanotrofi rumeni, negli anni '90,
hanno mostrato che bambini
che hanno vissuto una situazione
di deprivazione tattile
alla nascita, e nei primi anni di vita,
hanno poi mostrato delle difficoltà
nello sviluppo emotivo e cognitivo.
Ma va detto
che una successiva situazione familiare
accogliente, ed affettuosa,
può limitare, almeno in parte,
le conseguenze negative
a lungo termine di tali carenze.
Già prima della pandemia abbiamo assistito
ad una vera e propria
demonizzazione del tatto,
in cui si è prestata molta più attenzione
ai contesti, ai limiti,
ai modi in cui si toccava l'altro;
ma ora abbiamo tutti rinunciato al tatto.
Durante la pandemia, il tatto è il senso
che ha pagato il prezzo più alto.
Certo, molte persone hanno comunque
potuto avere interazioni tattili,
per esempio con i loro familiari.
Quindi non stiamo parlando
di una vera e propria
totale mancanza di tatto.
Piuttosto, abbiamo assistito
ad un graduale sviluppo di una paura,
di un timore verso il tatto,
essendo uno dei vettori di contagio.
Il distanziamento sociale, e l'isolamento,
sono stati accompagnati
da una vera e propria fobia
nel toccare non solo altre persone,
ma anche oggetti che usualmente tocchiamo
senza pensarci troppo,
come il carrello della spesa,
la maniglia della porta, un campanello.
Durante questi anni,
molte persone mi hanno chiesto
quali saranno le conseguenze
della pandemia per la salute mentale,
e se torneremo a toccarci come una volta.
Possiamo speculare, certo:
ma le conseguenze della mancanza di tatto,
dovuta al CoVid19,
si sapranno solo più avanti.
Quello che possiamo dire con certezza
è che siamo intrinsecamente,
e inevitabilmente, legati al tatto.
E che questo desiderio primordiale
di toccare, di essere toccati
e di comunicare attraverso il tatto,
risultato di milioni
di anni di evoluzione,
è veramente difficile da scardinare.
Per nostra fortuna.
Grazie mille.
(Applausi)